So we're starting to get to the wrap-up phase of this lecture.
And so I want to sum up what we've learned about the programming model so far.
So I want to try to sum this up in three points.
First, we know that when we write a kernel program
that program looks like it's only going to run on one threads.
However, when we launch that program and we launch the kernel from CPU code,
we specify the launch bounds of that such that
that program can be launched to run on any number of threads that we define.
Finally, within the kernel program, each one of those threads knows its own index
and its own thread block and then the grid of thread blocks,
so that it can properly pick up the right piece of work for it to compute.
Now, what we're going to do is take a slightly broader view of the kind of operations
that we just did in our sample program.
And what we're going to have is two ingredients
that we've learned that are going to lead to an interesting abstraction that we're going to call map.